all four
uh senate candidates in runoff election
are raising record funds led by one
democrat
rolling in the doe according to politico
ossoff brought in 106.8 million dollars
in two months making him the best funded
senate candidate in history
his opponent david perdue brought in 68
million dollars
in the same time frame now ossoff is the
democrat produced a republican
in the other race warnock brought in
103.4 million dollars while republican
kelly loffler
raised only 64. so the democrats have
raised 40 million dollars
more than the republicans so far the
previous fundraising record
for a u.s senate candidate was held by
democrat jamie harrison who raised 57
million
in his unsuccessful bid to defeat
senator lindsey graham in south carolina
all four of the georgia candidates
easily
surpassed that number having said that
tom thotts
ellsworth um i think they got it all
wrong
there are exactly 11 million people that
live in the state of georgia
11 million okay and listen to what was
raised
why doesn't somebody just send every
single one of them a 20 starbucks
card they could literally do this that's
right
with all this money they could they
could have just they could have said
listen this one would do
i think i think it's amazing it's it's a
testimony to what's hanging in the
balance and what's hanging the balance
is the us senate
and conservative or liberal legislative
principles
that's it zanner what do you think you
know i'm glad i don't live in georgia
that's all i can say i hate political
ads and can you imagine
how you're being it would ruin your
holidays that is correct it would be the
absolute worst now here's the craziest
thing about it
these democratic candidates are raising
so much money
it's it's literally insane over 100
million for one candidate for one race
but yesterday one of the narratives is
they're running out of money
that they're gonna have to choose pretty
soon between boots on the ground it
sounds like a war doesn't it
or tv ads and chuck schumer even came
out and said that he's quote unquote
pessimistic he
tried to back away from that comment a
little bit but pessimistic
about the democratic chances now they
have to run the table the democrats in
georgia they're going to win both of
them
right so the republicans only have to
win one there are so many interesting
subplots to this loffler you know who's
a very very
uh successful established credible
person getting torched
by the nba the wnba she's an owner in
the wnba
and they have from her team and the
entire league have basically mobilized
to to try to take her down
tick-tockers i have no idea let me tell
you credit to tick-tockers i mean people
cannot downplay the tick-tock
game it's insane i mean they had a hand
in the in the regular election
even leading into the debates and into
the primaries and even now now i will
say this happily there are some
republican-based
twit uh tick-tock groups too because you
only hear about the little liberals that
are out there trying to
stream things up that there's like one
conservative one that has 1.5 million
followers on theirs
so it looks like it's both ways but tick
tock i mean everything is going to make
a difference in this this election
because so much is at stake
yeah so here's here's here's what i can
tell you what i what i notice
i have given money to both republicans
and democrats
okay i've given money to both sides so i
receive email
from both sides okay i get emails from
republicans that send me money talking
about georgia i get emails from
democrats telling me
i have to tell you for every one email i
get
from republicans i get eight emails from
democrats
and the way they do it is so creative
they'll get different people
sending the emails and they'll say
you know one of them will say dnc
headquarters okay and obviously you know
that's coming straight from dnc
headquarters
i get that but then the rest will say
different names
james taylor michelle obama chuck
schumer
nancy pelosi they have a hundred names
that i get emails from so every time i
open it up and they'll say
patrick this year i went all in and
helping out like job
and then they'll go into this georgia
will you donate seven dollars directly
to dnc to flip georgia fund to help win
the runoffs elect the democratic control
senate and win a
essential races in a month so here's the
point i'm trying to make to you somebody
may say well pat why would you give to
both parties
strategically for me i want to learn
what both sides are doing that's one
two the approach that republicans are
taking versus democrats
i got to tell you democrats are playing
more often than republicans are
and and whether there's a part of this
where there is this confidence to say
we have it don't even worry about it
that's the problem sometimes when you
get too cocky
we have it don't even worry about it
where the republicans are going to pick
it up
listen there's no way in the world we're
going to lose both seats so they're not
playing offense
so they're raising 40 million less but
we know this week trump is going to
georgia i think january 40 is going to
be in georgia
to help those guys out who do you think
is going to end up winning here the way
it's looking like right now
god i i hope the republican republicans
are you hopeful are you are you like if
you want to put a logical hat and you're
betting money right now are you betting
your hundred thousand dollars on
republicans winning or you're betting on
democrats
100 i'm betting on the democrats
seriously absolutely they've been
harvesting votes for weeks
out there they've already got two
million votes that are already in
right um the way they've learned to play
dirty they've developed the the the
playbook
so they're just gonna you know apply it
to georgia here right now no i'm very
very worried
you know i'm not optimistic at all and
every day i accept expect something bad
or crazy to come out i mean there's even
some sort of crazy tie-ins to the
explosion in nashville
which we can talk about a little bit
later but no i would say the democrats
are probably gonna win this thing just
like they won in november
tom i so
what's good for america i'm gonna set my
views aside what's good for america
i think is a divided government that is
almost kind of uh neutralized against
itself so it doesn't sway
too far in either direction i think
that's good for america i get the
feeling kelly lofther is probably going
to win
her race by a nose which basically
will make that happen but i agree with
you the there has been so much effort
out there
it's tough to drop the fraud word
without
stuff right in front of me but um you
know when you see that
82 percent of confederate soldiers have
voted you know
i'm um i'm thinking you know there's
things going on
you know i wonder if these tick tockers
do they really know
all the ramifications of what they're
trying to do and how it ultimately will
affect them
i mean if this country is run
exclusively by the left
it's not great for every anybody really
truly except a lifelong politician maybe
people that want to have just absolute
power but it's so funny these guys
are so motivated and they do have power
and they do have influence and they do
have the energy to do this but
you sometimes wonder they're so young do
they even know what they're doing
it looks like they need to have an adult
in the room you know kind of guiding him
okay there's some repercussions here for
what you're trying to do do you really
know these candidates you're pushing for
peel back a little bit on their
histories a little bit and look at what
some of the stuff they've stood for in
the past and maybe you wouldn't be so
aggressive
you know to me every time one side is
about to win all three
the opposing side says what's best for
america is
to not have one side have all three
right but if the republicans have it
their way they'd love to have all three
if democrats have it there
they'd love to have all three if it's up
to the politicians because
it's easier in those two years to get
what everything done tom
don't hold back with this one tom be the
time of biz doc
give us the energy of tom not the one
that's safe they're trying to be a
little too worried about what could
happen
give us your brain we are relying on
your brain and processing
let me ask the question if everything's
won the democrats have senate
house and presidency what happens in two
years
in the first two years because it's not
going to be more than two years but what
can they get done in that two-year
period
i think either okay this is what i
let it go let's no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no we can go
back and see what what happens with
history
clinton got that in his first term yeah
and he attempted to ram through
the first version the great great great
grandfather of obamacare
he and hillary he appointed hillary as
first lady to this commission remember
and they ran that through
and the mid-term elections was one of
the biggest hell no's in american
electorate history
as the midterms flipped to bring balance
back the other way
i i am conservative i i want to see
kelly loffler win
because i think that's the best chance
for the senate holding up conservative
business policy and tax policy that i
care deeply about
but i i really think that if they win
all of it
they're going to fumble the opportunity
for two reasons one there's a civil war
going on in the democratic party
aoc is pissed that she doesn't have a
cabinet post or someone close to her
on the squad that has some sort of a
cabinet post so the
hard hard left is very upset with the
moderate left somehow
someway elizabeth warren is not in the
mix you know it's a more moderate
cabinet so there is a and
bernie so bernie liz aoc in the squad
there is a civil war on the democrat
side
pushing how real is that how realistic i
think it's i think it's
damn real is that just articles being
written on the right or is that really
happening
i think you look at the position of you
look at what aoc is saying and look at
the position of stuff i think you can
see it please
totally believe it totally they think
they can push through and they think
they're teflon
they literally do i mean they got voted
into the house you agree
i agree i agree i think they can't
believe anybody would be opposed to them
they want absolute power this squad and
what they're looking for
and they can't understand any resistance
to it whatsoever it just doesn't it
doesn't register for them so it will be
announced so
let me ask you a question so you asked
me about midterms yeah and i think i
think the pendulum will swing the other
way on midterms
because the wrong thing if i was running
strategy for biden i would say listen
the wrong thing
would be too much too soon while these
conservatives are still triggered and
activated midterms are going to come
quick
but i think they're going to go a little
too fast i think they're going to do a
little too much and i think it's going
to swing back the other way
i think biden at his heart is a little
bit old school i really do
i don't think he's buying into all this
i mean he did things a certain way for
40 years
he's used to back room deals you know in
the senate and he's been part of all of
this for the last four
40 years he's not going to embrace all
this radical change right away i'm
hoping
i'm giving him the benefit of the doubt
right now but i'll disagree with you
guys on one thing i think politicians
number one motivation
is self-preservation and i think if they
felt they owned
all three the house the senate and the
president
that they knew there would be such
turmoil in two years half of them would
be gone
so i think there's some sort of benefit
some on the left that are saying it's
not
i think deep down i don't think they all
believe
that it's the best scenario for their
party for themselves
because they can be swept away even a
long term congressman could be
you know sent packing in the upheaval in
two years so i think that
most of them are thinking i just want to
stay here i want to clean sail through
my next election in two years
and just stay here so i think that
they'd be okay
if if the democrats didn't control the
senate so
did biden come across now that this is
taking place now that's
already you know everything's going
through the way it is and the last thing
that's left is with you know pence you
know having to sign off and i think
pence is being sued right now
uh for possibly not being able to sign
off you know hold him back and you know
what things he could
he could do himself so biden's come
coming out now being way more moderate
than people thought he was gonna be
is he more moderate than obama was
or is too too too soon to tell i think
it's too soon but i think he'll
probably be if obama's in eight i think
he's gonna be like a six and three
quarter
okay so he's not going to be far left as
obama right and here's the other
difference between him and obama
obama had joe biden as vice president
who was pretty
passive joe biden has kamala harris who
is the opposite of joe biden as a vice
president
power hungry um she doesn't come for
that next move
she doesn't come with a stable full of
relationships from all those years in
the senate
joe biden brought that yeah you know he
may not have been
really valuable to obama at the boating
booth and he wasn't but he was
very valuable in terms of all the
relationships he had
all the all those years since i will say
i'm surprised he hasn't stuck one of
these squad members
in some sort of high-ranking cabinet
position to be honest with you i think a
lot of people are surprised what do you
think that says about him though i think
a lot of people are
so so here's a question this becomes a
question for me so there's there's two
arguments here
one is is this biden's doing
or is it the people behind closed doors
who put up the money saying listen
here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna put this person you're not
even gonna get close to any of these aoc
elizabeth warren guys
you're going to put the people that we
recommend you to put in janet yellen is
going to be fine
some of the things that's going to take
a hit on capital gain is going to take
place
some of the things that's going to
happen with taxes where it's going to go
you were talking about yesterday with me
from 33 to 39
that's going to take place but for the
most part is it biden's
strategy that's coming out saying here's
who i'm picking or is the money people
behind closed doors i think it's some of
the money that's keeping biden
kind of in the biden zone um i think
it's a lot of that
you know the money remember money
doesn't like change money
and money hates radical change
i think the words biden in strategy are
mutually exclusive i don't think he has
any strategy
not any big thinking he's the accidental
president
i mean he got thrown into this thing he
shouldn't even won the primary if you
think about it and here he is
as the president at 78 years old so i
think it's behind it's it's the group
behind
this is a this is a you know a group
effort a conglomerate behind him making
decisions
you agree i i absolutely agree i think
there's a group that's
that is strategically trying to keep
this moderate and then keep control
and move agendas forward and i don't
think they're
to be trifled with because i think they
want to move left but i think they want
to keep it from being
you know you know squad operation
let's not let's say he's not still
capable of putting complete buffoons in
some of these positions so let's see
what they do
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye